is there someone here who doesn't like
robert pattinson speak now show yourself
[Music]
and in today's noodle news yes guess who
dolly parton has just revealed the
secret to her mac and cheese
and you're not ready for this rod i am
not ready when i read what her secret
was i mean i love dolly parton she can
do no wrong but i was like maybe this is
her first misstep ever
insider reports dolly never serves mac
and cheese without get this
fried apples
and this unique combo platter happened
by accident one time dolly was just
making mac and cheese my soul sister
and tossed in some leftover fried apples
i've never tried that yeah and she had
them lying around and she never looked
back rossi well she wrote islands in the
stream so she had to try apples in the
cheese that's what she had to do i am so
excited because we have some here okay
i'm gonna try if it's if dolly can do it
i can do it
oh my god
golly
it's apple pie with cheese she actually
has
it
the mac and cheese is is secondary to
the apple in the most
complimentary and confident way
i want to say this right now on
television dolly parton i've never been
more wrong in my entire life
well first up in our in our news today
and stories is some noodle news for
almost a week it's about robert
pattinson oh you love robert pattinson
doesn't hello i don't know is there
someone here who doesn't like robert
pattinson speak now show yourself
well either i scared you or it is true
he is beloved by all in the cut reports
that the newest batman has his very own
pasta dream he wants to create the first
pasta you can hold in your hand and he
calls it pasta
cucino
he already has run experiments he sticks
together a lump of penne with layers of
sugar and cheese and coats it with corn
flakes and then microwaves it and he
says it should be served on a bun like a
hamburger it hasn't come together yet
but robert is serious he even met with
frozen food companies against the advice
of his management oh dear oh dear
i mean that's against nature don't you
think all that together with the cheese
and then he microwaves it and one of the
things that i found out um from digging
into the details was that he says all of
life's pleasure foods
burgers sandwiches tacos are all hand
friendly
but pasta is not and it's time for it to
be
okay well uh
[Applause]
next up
it's a story of the power of pancakes
the washington post reports that when
curtis kimball's wife told him that he
needed to make friends he threw a
pancake party
he posted flyers around his neighborhood
in san francisco saying my wife says i'm
getting a little weird so i'm making
some pancakes he set up griddles in his
driveway and a hundred people showed up
hungry for pancakes and pals
and then he did it again for 300 people
wow
and he hopes the idea spreads
no
i know
i love a man whose brain works like this
your wife is lonely you make pancakes
for the neighborhood and it fixes it
this isn't what you're someone who
thinks outside the box a little bit of
batter can make life a whole lot better
better up as i say yep
all right next up we have a story about
some incredible young people stepping up
in their community cbs news reports that
there is an emt shortage in america
in rural areas 35 percent of ambulance
services are volunteer and 69 of those
are under staff and in a small town of
sackett's harbor new york a group of
teens has taken the initiative to get
certified as first responders in order
to fill out their local emt force
they're also students attending high
school full-time but they say putting in
the extra hours to help others in their
toughest times is worth it to them
this is the stuff i need to hear about i
need that belief system that good things
are taking place and good people exist
you have my deepest respect and
admiration thank you so much to those
teenagers yeah
and they think
you think about
i think about how they always say oh
these kids these days kids these days
that's right i know what the future is
going to bring i just
when i read this story it made me feel
like if this is the future
the next generation maybe because of
kids like this we're going to be okay i
agree
[Music]
you